[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تتفاوت ساعات الصيام بين دوله واخرى
ومدينه وثانيه ليش لان الارض كرويه وان
شعاع الشمس مائل وبما اننا قريبين من نقطه
الاعتدال الربيعي فان فتره الصيام ستكون
متقاربه على جميع الدول تقريبا فاقل فتره
صيام في اول رمضان واطول فتره صيام في اخر
رمضان ليش لان رمضان كل يوم يزيد دقيقه
تقريبا وبما ان الشمس تقع الان شمال خط
الاستواء فان المواقع الجغرافيه الواقعه
شمال خط الاستواء ستشهد اطول صياما
بالعالم والمواقع الجغرافيه الواقعه جنوب
خط الاستواء ستشهد اقل صياما بالعالم حصن
صيامك بالسكوت عن الخنا اطبق على عينيك
بالاجفان لا تمشي ذا وجهين بين الورى شر
البريه من لهو
وجهاني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فاطول ساعات صيام على مستوى العالم ستكون
على النرويج واقريل لاند وفنلندا تصل
قرابه 23 ساعه واقل فتره صيام بالعالم
ستكون على جزر القمر وجنوب افريقيا
والارجنتين تصل قرابه 12 ساعه والدول
العربيه تتفاوت بين 14 الى 15 ساعه واطول
فتره صيام على الدول العربيه ستكون على
الجزائر وتونس تصل قرابه 16 ساعه رمضان
واقبل يا اولي الالباب فاستقبلوه بعد طول
غياب عام مضى من عمرنا في غفله فتنبهوا
فالعمر
ظل سحاب
[موسيقى]